-Also, we've had
an especially great week
because we've had Fred Armisen
back with us
leading the band on drums.
And Fred, every time I get
to spend a week with you,
the most delightful part
is hearing
about all your other projects,
the amazing things you're doing.
You just really are...
You are the multi-est
of multi-hyphenates.
-Thank you.
-And... this is obviously
the time of year
a lot of people
are going apple picking.
I heard that you just
bought an apple orchard,
but you're not going to use it
in the conventional way.
-No, I'm going to fill it more
with books,
because there's something
very not intellectual
about apple picking.
So I thought, well, how can we
make this a more brainy affair?
How can we do it
so that people discuss books
and talk about literature?
So, we don't have
the shelves quite yet,
but we've got, like,
piles of books.
So you go in there, and instead
of apple picking, pick a book.
[ Laughter ]
-So there are --
let me just clarify --
there are actual apple trees
with apples,
but you want people to come
and just go get a book instead?
-Yeah. So it's sort
of like, "Okay, great.
These are apples. Fantastic.
Let's talk about these books."
-So wait, I guess
my question would be,
it seems like you wanted
to open a bookstore,
and why wouldn't you
just do that?
-I thought the same thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-Like, why wouldn't I want
to just do that?
But then, I had the orchard,
and these people showed up,
and they, you know,
they bought tickets,
and I was like, "Look, let's --
let's talk instead.
Let's -- Let's read."
-Is it against --
Is it against the rules
if they want to get an apple?
-Yes. It's very --
So I want to tell everyone
it's very against the rules
if you want to get an apple.
-[ Laughs ]
What's it called?
-We don't have a name for it.
-Okay.
Why would you?
I feel like it's --
I mean, basically,
it sells itself.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-Thanks.
-Can I come?
-Please. Yes.
-Can I --
If I'm very hungry,
hypothetically...
I'm not --
I'm -- I'm not -- I'm not even
going to ask. [ Laughs ]